j'ai trouvé que la vidéo elle était top
honnêtement et c'était drôle et ça a
permis de donner une autre image en fait
deux
du gouvernement etc et je trouvais ça
sortait complètement d'un politique
et justement je pense que ça m'a fait du
bien après ce qui s'est passé j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt cool
après j'ai mes propres opinions et je ne
mélange pas du tout à ce que s'est passé
mais en tout cas ça fait du bien c'était
cool ça permet de rigoler alors pourquoi
emmanuel macron est il sorti de son rôle
de chef d'état parce qu'un ben justement
un chef d'état ne s'acoquine pas avec
des vedettes à la mode et il reste un
représentant du peuple français
élu au suffrage universel et il n'a pas
à s'acoquiner et à se mettre en avant
avec des stars de quelle qu'elle soit
c'est du clientélisme sait se vendre
auprès des plus jeunes auprès des plus
crédibles et des plus naïfs 20 je pense
que maintenant ils voiture et un
électorat beaucoup plus jeune donc il
l'a fait avec les moyens du bord sans
fin les youtuber de maintenant sont plus
que des youtuber c'est vraiment des
communicants et les gens ne seront
peut-être pas compte les jeunes que la
politique a beaucoup à faire dans dans
les nouvelles stade france faire on va
dire de médias et que pour moi macron il
n'est pas sorti de son rôle il a juste
utilisé parce qu'il avait en sa
possession pour attirer un nouvel
agathois bah pour moi c'est normal il a
en compagnie utilise tous les moyens
qu'il a pour pour aller en campagne je
vais dire mélenchon ou bien marine le
pen sont
aussi ils ont percé sur youtube macron
certes il a beaucoup plus de moyens pour
le faire et c'est peut-être dans ce sens
là qu'il est sorti son ossature qui l'a
peut-être utilisé des moyens qui n'était
pas au premier lieu étudiants fin
destiné à ça ça a permis de découvrir le
président sous un nouvel angle et de
voir un autre côté un autre aspect aussi
de l'elysée et après de pouvoir s'amuser
aussi prêt à skis et loisirs et après la
politique c'est autre chose
donc je pense pas que ça m'influence à
mois après à titre personnel après
peut-être pour les jeunes oui il est
déjà en fait dans une dynamique de
campagne présidentielle pour pour les
élections de 2022
et c'est effectivement que le public de
mac faye carlito et et un public jeune
voilà qui qui est très abstrait afin
qu'il ya beaucoup de d'absence voilà
dans dans les élections dans les
suffrages etc je pense que c'est aussi
peut-être façon de draguer ce public qui
lui échappe peut-être encore un petit
peu même si globalement il y est
favorable je pense alors pour moi c'est
vrai qu'ils pas tout le monde pas tous
les présidents et font ça mais c'est pas
mal parce que quand même avec les
youtuber ils peuvent quand même
communiquer avec les gens mion qui par
exemple quand il est un président
pasquet c'est vrai qui concerne
président qu'il parle tout le monde et
il cherche quand même de éviter des
écoutes est alors qu'ici c'est de
youtube est requis quand même tout le
monde
il regarde et il aime bien ça peut
passer mieux une parole à la place de
président moi je pense qu'il a vu le bon
côté par rapport aux jeunes après
critiqué une chose pareille c'est à dire
ça fait pas de mal à personne ça fait
rire tout le monde
et puis bah après politiquement je pense
pas mais lui ça lui fait toujours du
puits selon lui